what what is what are you making cooking
comments this is my
saturday my one day off benton has
ambushed me with a
bunch of bags of shit he's trying to
make me a wife
if you take a day off he'll come for
your spot is this like a
the floor's lava or something
competition show
no that seems more fun we both have to
cook
we have the same amount of time only
using the ingredients in this bag
yeah and these you have to use these and
you can also use whatever's in your
pantry or whatever's in the spice
cabinet
i'm going to start with a prayer i don't
know how you want to start don't bring
me into your
wicked rituals dear chrissy teigen
please give me the power to slay my
enemies
even if they are my friends uh let my
chef's knife be sharp and let the blood
flow like gravy
anything else i need to know how to cook
what is it i don't know i think i felt
like a ferret or something
hold on i'm gonna guess what this is
before
you know when there's a big sausage and
you cut the butt of it is this the butt
of a
like the butthole the butthole of the
sausage i bought a whole sausage and
then i cut just the butts off
this is some kind of chicken this is the
breast implant you didn't use
this is something you find in my bedside
drawer
am i right is that my iud
oh god i hope not it's benevolent bacon
it's beautiful
weiner oh it's a pack of four skin
how much time do we have 20
this is gonna ruin our relationship i i
feel it coming
hey this is a little trick my mom taught
me i think
where when you cut onions you first do
this i'm sure it's not meant to go
towards you you definitely do not cut
towards yourself
see how i just cut it whatever i just
did how do you like
me now future husband
what the peach pit name of
what restaurant in what famous show
the peach pit um baby fish club
what little show called beverly hills
oh i didn't know man while you were busy
learning how to cook as a child
i was watching that show oh this is fake
butter
you're fake butter true
can you quiet your sizzling down a
little bit i'm talking
do we own sugar do you want sugar you
don't live here
just because you you know have a game
plan
and just because you've been programmed
to behave a certain way
and you have habits it doesn't mean it's
about my cooking or about your therapy
are you paying attention to that clock
or what
no because time is an illusion raw
salmon is a delicacy in many cultures so
if i don't get to cooking it
i don't get it you're boiling those
peppers
i i'm doing a couple things using
peppers and carrots that you might not
understand
the lesson here is creativity
the lesson here is to put out work that
you're proud of spontaneity
well then you need to stop filming this
now
letting your soul take you hold on i've
seen my
how do you cut garlic
sometimes you have to open your mind and
be intuitive you know well
in the words of my ancestors in the
south i don't have to do nothing
can you take the skin off for me it'll
fall apart
and also you have to season that i know
wait how do i turn this one why is it
spitting
hold on okay easy okay now i'm in the
game this one is that one i just learned
that
we're not the hard way labeled yep no
again i don't i go by what i feel that
was meant to happen
the universe has a plan to the
firefighter
right you're just trying to eat raw
raw peppano pepper well no these were
going to be garnish on the top oh i
forgot about these fuck
these are good raw no they're not you
don't eat that roll
right now i am just sort of burning
famine
salty just like you the number one role
of being a chef is all just good
having a positive attitude i'm making
this reduction
who taught you the word reduction my
surgeon
this is my station this is your station
this is not hollywood you don't get
everything
let me see that potato okay
fully not cooked the only thing that
started me off is the kimchi
that's the only thing
what is this leave it alone that's a
sauce
it's a salsa oh my god i'm going to add
stuff that there's not
anything from your pantry
in that case you're about to lose even
harder
what the what are you doing
that sounds really bad it's called can
you see that on camera
it's called texture oh my god whitney
that is
delicious baby shit that's bad
i wish i had that
it doesn't look as good as it is
[Applause]
it's you know it's just too complex for
for most people to understand
oh you know anybody would change that
what do you do mine
no you can redo that you were trying to
be spoken
now now i'm depressed
let's just try on me not married
oh my god did you put cinnamon in there
how did wooden do this
are you not supposed to cook kimchi is
the whole point that it's raw
i don't really know how to use sketchy
so i'm just going with that
stupid i would say the person that's
winning is the person who is eating
their own food voraciously because it's
so delicious and irresistible
supposed to eat it it's for someone to
taste and you've already ate all the
meal this is the only time
in whitney's life that she'd ever not
strive for perfection and i'm a little
i'm a little confused the sauce i made
that looks like baby shit is actually
good
i feel like i'm raising a child you
are being like a mean mom
who keeps telling me off camera like
that looks delicious do you want me to
save this for you there's no off camera
i'm sorry i don't know how to saute
peaches
with kimchi but the bills get paid now
don't they
are you gonna pay attention to the timer
i do want to say
oh get the steam is good for the skin
sorry
[Music]
it's important to know your strengths
and your weaknesses and to be gentle
with yourself
when you don't now
you are panicking why
he's winning whatever this fucking thing
is
he's stressed out i'm doing great
i'm happy i'm chill i'm enjoying things
i'm eating carrots
peaches can i come no you cannot try
until we're done you need to cook your
meal
does the microphone pick all that
chewing oh god gross
that tastes like a pie okay good like a
delicious pie are you making salmon
pot pie i'm trying to stick to um
something you can put on a menu
at a place what prison
if you do not put cutting towards
yourself you're really using lots of
spices and stuff
i'm keeping it simple flavorless very
wide of you
i mean we're having a cooking
competition for youtube i don't know how
much lighter this can get
i feel like learning how to cook at this
point is an
fu to all of the chefs out there who are
struggling during the pandemic who
frankly need the business
you know i feel like cooking your own
food at this point is ungrateful
and frankly unpatriotic i
would like all the men out there
watching to know i do have other
qualities
i have a sauna i have a pool i
can suck a dick like you've never seen
editing
is there anything we won't fight about
look there's a fly coming
with your food no it's it knows what it
knows
it knows delicious food when he sees it
honestly might make it taste better at
this point
like when you know when you whisk a
sauce i have a theory that
chefs made that up just so they could
see women's boobs jiggle
my boobs don't jiggle that much because
you know they're fake
why why at the finish line be so lazy
lazy yeah right there you did so much
with that now you're just like
that's what i wanted to look like what
did you want it looks like i don't know
just a little more
okay oh you have anything on a plate
we'll talk about it
okay hold on okay
pencils down
well i'm out of time
it's a little fishy and that's on the
fish
what do you think i'm gonna do sabotage
your food yeah it's really negative and
anti-woman
you think all women are sneaky and
conniving and manipulative
not all women
stop saying about my food louis how
gross does this look
yours looks better i know i agree
yeah i agree you did some weird
like money shot on your carrots at the
end
i was gonna say you did some weird like
splooge situations
yeah so there's technically peach on
this
oh kimchi garnish
i didn't steal some
genuinely stressed out genuinely used my
size so much in life
genuinely liked my sauce i didn't like
that after all
it literally just yeast okay
it's just an ingredient that totally
worked it was a great choice that's the
only reason i like that just like if i
made something
covered in hot sauce like i obviously
like hot sauce
oh cooking video is this stressful this
is so good though nutritional yeast
i put it in everything on everything
around everything i snort it
i know yeast makes you think infection
which is not appetizing
but it's delicious it literally says
adds delicious flavor on the front of
the package yeah
what did you do uh i panicked and just
threw a bunch of shit in a pot
all right i made a mashed red skin
potatoes
with vegan bacon and sauteed
onions in it but what you did was you
cut up the onions you took the vegan
bacon chopped it up
and then you put like butter in a pan in
the video that you watched
and then i mixed it in with the potatoes
that i mashed with heavy whipping cream
what kind of whipping cream heavy
whipping cream okay then i took my
ball no pepper i cannot say that word
have wine
i diced up garlic smashed it mashed it
put tahini on it
oh my stomach hurts i bet it does i had
the whipping cream agave
cinnamon butter made that into like a
sauce put the pizzas in there let them
sit until they got soft
then i cooked the salmon and was left
over of it with some red pepper flakes
on it
salt and pepper and um then for anything
i also tried to grow my my kimchi don't
do that you learned anything here today
don't cook kimchi and don't marry me
or me no you're seriously wipe material
but that's for a different reason what
did you do with this
i steamed my peppers my carrots my
potatoes
with some garlic and some onions and
eyeballs she didn't steam anything she
boiled them in a pot of water i boiled
them
because you were hogging all of the hot
areas
all the hot circles the hot circles and
then you boiled yeast
in a bowl yeah and then you pretend to
choose the other ingredients
it was like a ratatouille most of the
rat part
um uh buy the merch
no we need to get our verdict i really
don't care i think vendor should win
you do i think benjamin earned it good
news
there were a lot of ingredients near
each other
they're definitely cut wasn't my turn
seven's great is it ever not your turn
minton
love the potatoes the questions were
fantastic but i think that whitney's
sauce was the real highlight on the
vegetables
which is why i stole it when i made her
go kitchen i knew what i was doing
the real winner the vegetables
were just go work with her
i can't get a call back we're a good
team
and i think that's what we've learned
here today is that without it you learn
that too
what are you doing i'm gonna make this
into a shot laugh and put heavy cream in
it
why because i like to have fun
okay this was great uh whitney had a
really fun time as you could tell
like and subscribe to this channel
please buy our merch
store.windycomings.com
please leave us voicemails and other
things that we should make thank you for
watching
um no i'm not singing i'm not clown
i can sing private dancer i'm your prima
i can't believe you used this sheath
critter on that peach